absolutely delighted that Thomas Cashman
has been found guilty of the murder of
Olivia
um you know devastating for her family
simply can't imagine the pain that
they've been going through since August
last year and I absolutely send my
heartfelt condolences to the family I
know the conviction today is not going
to bring Olivia back it's not going to
ease the pain of losing a daughter
bought some small comfort
person who snuffed out the life of
Olivia far too early is now facing a
life sentence behind bars I would
describe him as a coward despicable
he
decided on that night
or decided in the days beforehand to
play out a petty dispute using guns on
the streets of merseyside in the
community of dovecott and that has had a
devastating impact for Olivia's family
which we they will live with for the
rest of their lives
every waking moment and every moment
they go to sleep
he made great play in the in the trial
that he is a dad
and yet he's put Olivia's family through
this trial I hope he reflects every
morning when he wakes up behind bars and
every night when he goes to sleep about
what he's put Olivia's family through a
cowardly criminal who decides to take
the law into his own hands and settle
Petty disputes by using toot by using
two firearms anybody who does that
they're not thinking about the
consequences they don't care about
anybody who lives in their communities
he was just intent in settling what was
a petty dispute and the consequences
were Olivia's family are devastating do
you believe you are on top of gang
culture and organized crime in Liverpool
I absolutely do but I recognize that
that is on the back of this year where
we've had five people who've been killed
um in in firearms in Firearms murders
but merseyside is recognized by hmic FRS
as outstanding in the in our approach to
tackling serious and organized crime
we've got really strong uh teams in
place to tackle Firearms crime we have
seen in merseyside
um we are at the lowest number of
firearms discharges that we've seen in
20 in 20 years
um you know in 2012 we saw 125 Firearms
discharges in 2021 that number was down
at 39 so we are taking a positive and
successful approach to tackling gun
crime on the streets of merseyside
likewise with our approach to serious
and organized crime but I say that when
five people have lost their lives and to
me that is you know the time to renew
our commitment to working with our
partners and we're working with our
communities together to make sure that
those offenders can't operate here in
merseyside